- Ils savourent une première
victoire en entonnant quelques
notes.
♪ Ce n'est qu'un début
continuons le combat! ♪
- Les locataires de la résidence
Mont-Carmel viennent d'obtenir
une ordonnance de la Cour
supérieure qui permet de garder,
pour le moment, la vocation
de leur immeuble, qui est une
résidence privée pour aînés.
- C'est une belle victoire.
- Nicole Jetté, 79 ans, porte la
cause avec 56 autres résidents.
- Cette décision du juge, nous
la devons à un mouvement
extraordinaire de solidarité.
- Le 31 janvier dernier,
ils ont eu toute une surprise
quand ils ont reçu un avis
d'éviction leur disant que
l'immeub s sera transformé
en complexe locatif
multigénérationnel alors
que le nouveau propriétaire
s'était engagé à respecter
sa vocation actuelle
de résidence pour aînés.
- Vous me dites qu'il y a
des gens, en recevant l'avis
d'éviction, qui ont fait
des AVC. Il y a eu un AVC?
- Oui j'ai eu mmeme
la confirmation ce matin
par l'infirmière.
- Les locataires ont
en main une première manche,
mais constatent avec regret
une diminution des services.
Il n'y a plus de salon
de coiffure, ni de dépanneur.
- Pensez à un déménagement, là,
dans l'état où je suis? Ce que
je veux, c'est que nos droits
soient respectés!
- Et la directios's'est fait
discrète lors de notre pasgege.
La député de Québec solidaire
a commenté l'affaire en disant :
- On est fiers de ce qu'on
a fait. Et puis, je trouve que
ne serait-ce que ça, ça a valu
la peine de se tenir debout!
- Plusieurs locataires dans
l'immeuble qui sont prêts à se
battre et qui continuent àee
battre et qui sont, je pense,
très heureux d'avoir eu
une décision en leur faveur
qui fait en sorte que maintenant
le propriétaire à l'obligation
de maintenir la certification
et l'exploitation de la RPA,
à tout de moins jusqu'au19 sept.
- Le 19 septembre, c'est
le moment ou la Cour va
entendre les parties afin
de déterminer si le tribalal
compétent pour entendre
l'affaire est le Tribunal
administratif du logement
ou la Cour supérieure.
En attendant, les résidents,
eux, gardent le cap.
Ici Mélissa François
Radio-Canada, Montréa